baksi se ha bautizado como el que nací
en una familia cristiana en una época
tuve malas amistades y eso me hizo
cuestionarme muchos tipos de queso
cuando tenía 17 años tuve la biblia el
corán y la torah y desde ese momento fui
a las mezquitas estudie aprendí árabes y
desde entonces me convertía al islam
para mí la religión cualquiera que ésta
sea es sobre todo cuestión de
espiritualidad y de amor que el que le
soir según sus estudios
el club salió al mercado el año pasado
lo creé el año pasado se trata de un
calendario del ramadán es como el
calendario de adviento en efecto este
año en limo 6000 se nos agotaron todos
los niños van a poder vivir plenamente
todo el mes de ramadán
cada día los padres van a poder
compartir con sus hijos un rato para
educar los valores que están detrás de
cada casilla
[Música]
en el islam la mezquita es la casa de
dios la mezquita de cantel eeuu es una
mezquita prácticamente nueva es la
primera mezquita de normandía es muy
grande y bonita aprecio muchísimo este
lugar pero me hubiera gustado que fuera
una casa con entramado de madera típica
de normandía y representar el islam en
todas sus facetas hacer que caigan las
barreras y las inquietudes excepto un
vélez desde aquí tweet